ma fille aurait eu 11 ans caché derrière
un tableau pour protéger l'identité de
la fratrie et entouré de centaines de
peluches la mère de la fillette de
Granby a exprimé toute sa peine et sa
colère jamais j'aurais pu penser qu'un
enfant
à 7 ans pour répartir dans des
circonstances comme cela pour elle le
système a carrément abandonné sa fille
qui était sous la garde de son père et
de sa belle-mère pourtant elle dit avoir
alerté à plusieurs reprises la DPJ des
abus que subissaient l'enfant qu'on ni
le fait que ton enfant a des Bleus qu'on
ni le fait qu'il y a des brûlures qu'on
nie le fait que cet enfant-là se fait
battre qu'elle se fait maltraiter
je peux pas
croire qu'on nous est ignoré la mère de
la fillette et ses grands-parents
paternels poursuivent le centre de
service scolaire du Val des serres le
sud de l'estruchus et personnellement
trois intervenants et un chef de service
de la DPJ il réclame plus de 3 millions
700000 dollars en dommage punitif ces
intervenants ont ignoré les drapeaux
rouges les faits accablants alors que
cette petite fille appelée au secours
elle avait le droit à l'attention des
personnes en charge de la protéger elle
avait le droit à la dignité le droit au
secours lorsque sa vie était en danger
la poursuite reproche au milieu scolaire
d'avoir ignoré la détresse de la
fillette malgré des signalements
d'enseignants elle a été retirée de
l'école des pleurs mettent à soulignes
après tout ce qu'ils ont observé ils ont
recommandé l'école à domicile sachant
sciemment que
cet enfant était en danger chez elle on
se débarrasse pas d'un enfant
un mois après son dernier jour de
fréquentation scolaire elle est morte
son père et sa belle-mère ont été
reconnus criminellement responsables et
sont présentement incarcérés la
grand-mère paternelle qui a eu la garde
de la fillette pendant les premières
années de sa vie en veut aux
institutions
non c'est pour les protéger et
partir
ce qui devait faire centre de protection
de la jeunesse qui veut dire protéger
les enfants subvenir à ce qu'il ne
souffre pas subvenir à ce que cet enfant
ne reste sur toi le scius et le centre
de service scolaire ont refusé de
commenter en raison de la
judiciarisation du dossier les
procédures s'annoncent longues les
parties doivent se présenter devant le
tribunal le 26 octobre ici Marie-Hélène
Rousseau Radio-Canada Sherbrooke